THEAL WNTA
ANOTR P AS ENDHE  BUSINESS HT NI
THE MONEY, OT OSI SAYS HI WTEXC,
RIGHT?
EXACTLY RIGHT.
DEMOCREEN FM
AR
SP PELOSI AND
MA CLEARD
STAT AND LOCAL ALSO PUBLICANS H.
HEREHA BEHIND  THE KNOWHIS
PO
MNUCHIN DOR
RELATION WAK DEMOCRATIC LEADER T
SENATE.AM HAD BERKINGH S TO SEE
ISROVEN UNANOUES THANS ARE
HAVINGBLWI. DOATE ISUT
IN 2
THEY HOPEHA  G TOSBPROGRAM DURIO
NEXT WEEK AND SOME OF THE
CONCERNS I AM HRI N THAT UNLESST
BREAKTHROUGH OCCSSOON. FINAL O
PROGRAM IS.
RE
N AMERICANS FILINGEMOYS
WS PAY IRNOT AMULUS IF YOU WILL.
A LIFE TO FOR
SU CHECK.
THE IDEA BEING THAT YOU CANLO
EMPLOYED EVEN IF THERE ISTH COM
DO O PERIOD OFTIME.AT MOW DRY A
THAT
SUZANN CLAOINING
IT ISOO CHAMBE
S S N D SH H TODAYT THISCOULD O
PAY THEIR EMPLOYEEC
THISPASSE?
>>KNOW HOW IMPORNTFUNDINM THEM
NEED CONGRESS AND WE EXPECTRESY
DISPLAY T THE CARESCT WE KNOW TL
BU T PAY THEIRANTRLOAT.
>> YOUR BESTHE
THE PRESIDENT IS GOINGREESODHEW
THIS.>>TINUE DOGAT I WOULD LIKE
WIXT IN COORDINATION STATES TO .
O PROJECT
THAT PERIOBONTH. IS LONGTI CERIC
ICTN . HE TALKSNA
THATNNSYLV,
JERSCONNECTI SE
THROUGH THE OF MAY.
THETRICT
KE IOID
>> THERE IS AITICAL
DISAMEWEEN THET TSER TIN TOEN,
ISS CONFUSION NOW MAKING IT
HARDER?
>> THINK FORINESSES TRYING
RE, TESTIONS THA A TO USE THIS
TO MAKE AN.
ANTICAHEAD AND WHEN
GREEN LIGHTMEARE ALLF  NNDAININ
THAT ANGBE OBUSINE T NEVER HAD .
THERE IS NYBOOK.ITING FOR DERAL
FIGURE I
UN BUSINSECE HAVE A LOT ADY A
PERSONAL
ISTANCING AND
ALL T  1 PEOPLE ARE NOT GOEADY .
>> THINK THISION
MISSES THEINT.
A LOT PEOPL CTI
TO WORK ENTIRE TI.
THERE ARE A L WORKERS WHO
CURRENTLYT
WH LM THO
BUSINESSES WHO ARE A LOF WHO ARC